es tu as eue
bien le bonjour à tous nous sommes
actuellement en lorraine
de retour avec mamie twink aisée car y'a
et françoise dans les catacombes avec
nous cette fois pas dans les catacombes
on va aller dans une sorte d'hôpital
abandonné comment tu appelle ça déjà un
sanatorium sanatorium donc un hôpital
qui est soigné les gens malades de
tuberculose très bien et cet hôpital là
il a la particularité d'être présumé
hanté et là à 2 parce que oui on n'y va
que tous les deux en fait voilà donc on
aura juste un talkie walkie pourrait
être lié à françois les écarts qui
interviendront en cas de problème et
puis voilà on a dix minutes de forêt à
traverser avant d'atteindre le
sanatorium vous vouliez une exploration
horrifique je crois que vous l'avez et
puis on va voir si c'est la panique
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
en fait je
e
au pif droit
[Musique]
15 rapproche actuellement du lieu est
juste à côté selon les dires de florian
devrait pas tarder à arriver
on aperçoit au bout du luot juste là on
recommence à se rapprocher
[Musique]
hu
on y est on y est [ __ ] c'est super
grand bois on n'est pas les premiers à
venir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
france 2 ne le font pas car c'est juste
section la durée d'ouverture
ok
aller allons-y fonction est le reflet
moi ce qui me fait peur pour le moment
c'est le reflet de nos lumières dans les
vitres ça me fait super porsche pas
pourquoi je suis pas bien bon allez
avançons
la haute classe 2 hier elle cuisine
ses toiles à temps
douch
ça c'était les douches et encore une
bassine camp
les escaliers
tu as encore en face à l'ascenseur qui
est encore là
kim injuste plus trop courte
moi qui ai recommencé à monter commis à
des tâches
quatre étages 4 et 1
et c'est super contre
sur les trucs s'affirme n'ai rien contre
0 en 16 mois au plus tard
t'imagines on voit un mec à la fenêtre
c'est très silencieux pour le moment il
n'y a aucun bruit bizarre mais c'est
mais c'est pas pour autant que je suis
sera en fête
c'est pas pour autant que je suis ça
parce que je sais très bien qu'à m'en
vais avoir un bruit et vu qu'on aura
fait 20 minutes de silence
il va nous effrayer tu veux continuer à
monter
je
on
moi
qu'est ce que c'était que ça je pense
c'était ici vous menez le linge
brassée de la machinerie ici c'est de la
grosse machinerie c'est la grosse
machinerie ce serait cool de voir la
machinerie de l'ascenseur
je crois qu'on la voit dans un grenier
dans le grenier pour information c'est
un lieu qui a été abandonné il ya
maintenant onze années donc il est quand
même assez vieux enfin je veux dire ça
fait assez longtemps par exemple celui
au japon je crois que c'était il ya 7
ans 8 ans je crois qu'il est amené fin
bref d'accord tu vois quand onze ans bah
ça se dégrade un truc de ouf
[ __ ] on va se diriger dans la deuxième
elle parce qu'il ya tu veux dire quelque
chose raconté rapidement l'histoire du
dew ouais on est dans un ancien
sanatorium
donc c'est ici qu'ils venaient en fait
soigner des jambes malades de
tuberculose au début du 20e siècle
puisque cet hôpital en fait il ya de 19
ans de 19 100 des dons qu'il a plus de
100 ans
[ __ ] et ils y ont construit parce qu'à
l'époque la tuberculose c'était une des
plus grandes causes de mortalité il y
avait vingt pour cent des morts sont des
gens qui mouraient de tuberculose temps
c'était une maladie pulmonaire
c'était son vélo qui devait regrouper
des gens qui avaient la tuberculose dans
un hôpital pour éviter la contagion
et surtout pour les soigner à grande
échelle comme avec les purs et est basée
sur de l'air frais de la cure et au
début du 20e siècle c'était
l'industrialisation
donc il y avait énormément du sinn et il
y avait un exemple mais tu vas dire tout
le monde aller en ville pour trouver du
travail
du coup les villes étaient ultra
polluées s'était les conditions
d'hygiène étaient très mauvaises et
lyons à favoriser le débat avance des
blocs de verre coloré dans concret des
hôpitaux
un peu à l'écart dans la campagne ici on
est rond hauteur on surplombe la vallée
j'ai une anecdote j'ai une soeur de ma
grand mère qui est morte la turquie lors
face à son copain qui l'a refilée à
signer un bon tour de coupe très
longtemps et elle l on est mort de ce à
quoi il lui avait si lé coach 3g +
contraire quoi même si j'ai la vie du
site et c'était à l'époque ces mêmes n'y
a pas si longtemps que ça en fait tu
vois on n'est pas des oufs en sciences
comme maintenant je sais qu'aujourd'hui
c'est encore une
les maladies qui tuent le plus sauf que
dans le pays elles n'existent quasiment
plus parce qu'on vit plus dans des
conditions si précaire ils ont décidé
que les plus pauvres ne devait pas payer
pour être soigné d'accord mais ceux qui
avaient les moyens pouvaient payer et
donc ceux qui paient et que promet
deuxième étage avec la bellevue bas et
ceux qui n'avaient pas les moyens de
payer il était soigné mais avait l'an
dernier mais n'avait pas une belle vue à
ok on ne va pas faire la partie des
riches ceux qui avaient la bellevue
parce que ces exposés mais sur des
habitations en fait il ya des gens qui
peuvent nous voir on n'a pas envie de
mettre fin cette exploration car la
police débarque du coup on se dirige
vers le grenier à certains traits de
grenier voit à settat pas blaguer c'est
le vrai grenier
vrai de vrai grenier
pas sûr
je pense que c'est le mécanisme
ah ben voilà de l'ascenseur il est là on
en parlait [ __ ]
c'est clair que tu étais tu étais mieux
quand avait de l'argent quand même
[ __ ] je trouve ça beau d'avoir pris la
décision de soigner gratuitement les
gens qui n'avaient pas l'argent pour
pour payer leurs soins quoi
aujourd'hui avec la sécurité sociale on
a un peu ça toujours à l'époque ait pas
de sécu ce bail avait une sorte
d'observatoire ballon
mais en gros ici tu pouvais te poser et
admirer la ville de la vallée
on ne paie ni on voit pas grand chose
mais au début du 20e siècle n'est pas
tout ça au loin tu avais les usines à
l'épaisse fumée à 20 kilomètres d'ici on
était en allemagne en fait ainsi quand à
la fin de la guerre de 10,6 en 10 21 ans
l'allemagne avait annexé une partie une
grande partie de la modèle l'alsace est
une petite partie de meurthe et donc ici
on était en territoire français il y
avait eu un mouvement d'exode de
français qui voulait pas devenir
allemand c'est donc cassé pour revenir
encore et tu as eu la peau plus rien
bruit
il ya un bruit sera à plus tard après tu
sais on est sur les toits mec je pense
qu'ici les oiseaux ils doivent se
régaler quoi redescendre en bas
on va voir les chocs de riches ok
descend vite merci merci à toi qui a mis
ce message qui leur confiance
quand tu m'as fait part
restez dessous commune oui c'est ça qui
a fait part des quatre sous
la peur de quelqu'un soya ou discutent à
faire des séries c'est un lieu réputé le
plus hanté de la région quoi voilà il a
la réputation d'être hantée qu'on puisse
y il voir des
[Musique]
phénomène comme l'apparition de
silhouettes d'orb ou pve cpv eu ses
pairs versus tu as des articles de
presse anp sur un wiki qui disent que le
dieu a la réputation d'être hantée banon
les attire pas trop quoi laisser mes
moments c'est très calme
la caméra est en place j'ai plus qu'à
attendre et voir si on entend quelque
chose il ya aucun bruit suspect c'est
plutôt tranquille
mais on va aller dans la cave du lieu
c'est l'entrée de la cave
[ __ ] well colonel
voilà
c'est un super grand
elle a été condamnée donc les portes
chanac pour éviter que les zombies
[ __ ] merde pourquoi ils étaient
combien entendu un bruit
j'écris entendent ainsi m
non
peut-être ai-je entendu
bon on a fait le tour du lieu on va
maintenant devoir traverser la forêt
finalement je pense c'est ça le plus
beau ouais en fait moi je t'ai dis je
j'angoisse des forêts jeu ça me fait
angoisse est parce que tu es un
sentiment d'impuissance qui est
exceptionnel tu vois tu as une
visibilité de merde
il ya un milliard de boules autour de
toi tu si un vent très bruyant mais qui
marche sera pas le
jean raibaut traversions rejoindre nos
amis
[Musique]
c'est bon allez voilà le françois
françois de retour oui ils font affaire
nous attendent en vain joueurs sont
autour du feu ça se met bien en nous
attendant c'est vrai que ça chauffe là
c'est fini
c'était impressionnant comme comme lieu
parce qu'en plus il est il est en
altitude et il est aussi le lieu
lui-même et en hauteur en tout comme
l'hôtel qu'on a faits au japon
c'est assez fou du coutal décor du
grenier le décor des pièces les corps de
mike capps et trois ambiances très
différentes l'aller et le retour c'était
très dur pour moi parce que j'ai très
très peur des forêts en pleine nuit ça
me terrifie le challenge ça va être deux
dans une prochaine vidéo de passer une
nuit entière dans une forêt n'hésitez
pas à nous dire si l'idée vous plaît et
se défait à belz au ciel vous a plu
comme d'habitude et a passé voir la
chaîne de ce monsieur qui s'appelle la
même étude qui fait d'autres
explorations plaint d'ailleurs
essentiellement sans moi du coup on n'a
fait que deux ensemble sur un total d'
sur une trentaine sur une trentaine dont
vous en avez 28 à rattraper allez les
voir au revoir au revoir françoise elle
est où là allez salut
[Musique]